[Music]
there's a market for what we do that is
skepticism what is skepticism it's just
a scientific way of thinking so why
aren't scientists doing this because
they're busy doing their own thing in
their particular fields what the
skeptical movement has developed is a
set of tools like the baloney detection
kit a set of tools to deal with
particular claims that are on the
margins of science like creationism
intelligent design theory you know the
anti vaccinations the Holocaust
revisionists you know all these
conspiracy theories and and so on all
these alternative medicines and you know
there's a whole hundreds and hundreds of
these claims that are all connected to
different Sciences but the scientists in
those particular fields are too busy
working in their research to bother with
what these claims are because the claims
really aren't about those fields they're
just hooked to them they're about
something else because like back in the
80s when I first saw some professional
scientists debate Duane Gish the young
earth creationists you know they did not
fare well and I saw some Holocaust
historians debating or confronting
Holocaust so-called revisionists or
deniers they did not fare well because
they didn't know the special arguments
that are being made by these fringe
people that have nothing to do with the
science really they have an agenda and
they're using these little tweak
questions to get at it the mainstream
and try to debunk it for their own
ideological reasons so for example like
Holocaust revisionists I make this big
deal about why the door on the gas
chamber at madhouse and doesn't lock I
mean if it doesn't lock how are you
gassing people if you can't lock the
door you know so they must not a gas
people in there so if they didn't gas
people at Matt house and they probably
didn't gas people at any of the death
camps and if they didn't gas people
attending the death camps then they must
not have been a Holocaust what wait a
minute what yeah well from this door
that doesn't lock well I eventually went
and found out that that wasn't the
original door that took me a couple
years that's the kind of specialty thing
that skeptics do that mainstream
scientists scholars historians don't
have time to do so over the 25 years not
just us there's other skeptic magazines
and conferences and
you know and groups of people that meet
meet ups and so on all over the world
and it's because we've because of
the internet especially this whole idea
of what we now call fake news
alternative facts has gotten bigger and
bigger and it just gets unfolded in real
time online within minutes and hours and
we have to jump on it fast and so that's
really in part what we do so that's what
we've been doing for 25 years is kind of
putting out brushfires here and there
but also developing a set of tools that
can apply to any future ideas because I
don't know what's gonna be popular in
five years from now heck I don't know
what's gonna be trending tomorrow you
know who knows so you got to have these
tools at the ready and that's what we've
been doing at skeptic magazine but let's
address let's address the college campus
issue these days okay I I really think
this goes back to the 1980s I noticed at
first when I was in graduate school the
second time when I got a PhD in the
history of science my first round was in
the 70s in experimental psychology
graduate school and I didn't notice any
of this campus stuff in that in the late
80s when I was in my doctoral program
because history deals a lot with
literature the kind of post modernist
deconstruction of what texts mean I was
really taking off and so I initially
thought what is this you know but okay
I'll give it a shot
I'll keep an open mind here and just try
to follow the reasoning and I can kind
of see where they were going okay so
what is the true meaning of Jane
Austen's novel here or or Shakespeare's
play there or you know this novelist or
that author and I can see that there may
not be one meaning you know maybe the
author meant it as kind of a provoking
you to think about certain deep issues
and you have to find your own meaning in
the text okay I couldn't understand that
but then it kind of starts started to
spill over into history because this is
what I was and I was studying the
history of science and I kind of like to
think of science is progressing towards
some better understanding of reality
that I believe is really there and as
it's not the science is perfect and
we're gonna get to a perfect
understanding of reality I know I know
that's not going to happen but it's not
the same as literature it's not the same
as
as art and music it's it's it's
different than that you know if Darwin
hadn't discovered evolution somebody
else would have in fact somebody did
Alfred Russel Wallace the discoverer
natural selection is the mechanism of
evolution and if if Newton hadn't
discovered the calculus somebody else
would have well they did Leibniz and so
on these are things that are out there
to be discovered and I see that
differently than art and music and
literature which is constructing ideas
out of your mind and and so I don't
think that the postmodern kind of
deconstruction of the text applies
completely to history and you can see
immediately why it fails because this is
what led to in the 90s the whole
Holocaust denial movement so-called
revisionist they call themselves
revisionist and the argument was all
history is texts it's just written by
the winners and the rent winners write
themselves as the good guys and the
losers are the bad guys and and this is
all unfair and and and look maybe the
winners here have unfairly critiqued
Hitler and the Nazis and so on
yeah but what about that Holocaust thing
you know it looks pretty bad yeah yeah
well maybe it didn't happen the way we
have been led to believe it happened
because again the history of the
Holocaust was written by the winners
okay you can see immediately why this
kind of textual analysis can cascade
into complete moral relativism and
insane ideas like Holocaust denial
that's when I thought okay this is wrong
that this has gone too far and in the
mid-90s after the skeptics we founded
the skeptics and skeptic magazine in 92
this is one of the earliest things we
started going after because it was
around 95 or so that the so-called
science wars took off and that you know
science is just another way of knowing
the world no different no better than
any other way of knowing the world wait
wait wait time out what was that part
about you know we're just like everybody
else
science has his flaws but it's not just
like art or music it's different so then
by the 2000s I think this really
trickled down into all the sites all the
social sciences anthropology biology
evolutionary biology and just attack
attack attack to the point where any
particular viewpoint that an oppressed
minority finds offensive or anybody
finds a fence
can be considered a kind of hate speech
or a kind of violence you can sort of
see the reasoning from back the 1980s
all the way through to today you can see
how they get there but we should have
drawn that line and stopped well a bunch
of us tried to stop it back in the 90s
and well it had a momentum of its own so
I really think this whole idea of we
have to protest ben shapiro because he's
conservative and he's pro-life and this
is evil and wrong and it's hate speech
and it leads to violent wait wait wait
ben shapiro is a really smart guy and if
you can't refute his pro-life arguments
i'm pro-choice
i think i think i could beat him in a
debate i could at least tie him in a
debate but if you if you don't even know
his arguments because you don't want to
listen to him and you're gonna shout him
down well credit kudos to the berkeley
people who let him speak you know
recently but boy that has not been the
trend recently and this is the problem
the problem is this none of us has the
truth the only way to find out that if
you're deceiving yourself or not if
you've gone off the rails if you're
wrong in some way is to listen to other
people who disagree with you and this
these were the original arguments laid
down by John Stuart Mill 1859 on Liberty
this is the classic work one I might be
partially wrong and so by listening to
somebody who disagrees with me I get to
correct my idea too I might be
completely wrong and off the rails and
boy a good thing I heard this out before
I went too far three I might be
completely right but I'm not hundred
percent sure about my arguments and
hearing somebody on the other side helps
me refine my arguments and strengthen my
arguments if I can refute that
conservative or that radical leftist or
whoever it is and then how much stronger
my position is and and for it's not just
it's not just the speaker's right to
speak it's the listeners right to listen
maybe I the protestor don't want to hear
this person but maybe there's people in
the room but do want to hear this person
for whatever reason it's none of my
business so and then finally in terms of
moral progress that you know that I like
to track one of the biggest drivers for
the last five centuries has been the
principle of free speech this is at the
basis of all liberal democracies of all
civil society
these that everybody must have the
freedom to express their points of view
no matter how much we dislike them I
don't care if you're a Nazi or you think
we didn't land on the moon or whatever
your ideas are go ahead and tell us your
best arguments and we'll see we'll see
in the marketplace of ideas how well you
do and it's been my experience that this
is the quickest way to silence somebody
like you know the Holocaust deniers
don't lock up david irving in jail like
they did in austria when he showed up at
the airport
heck no let him give his talk in a
public forum and expose his ideas for
the craziness that they are for the lies
that they are and then everybody could
see it end of story but if you lock him
up then people are gonna move what's he
got to say must be really good because
they won't let him say it yes the
opposite effect you know the band in
Boston effect so that's that's my
argument for free speech and why these
college kids have gone off the rails
here let the people speak if you invite
them
[Music]